se trata del primer grupo de
combatientes extranjeros que
voluntariamente llegan para luchar codo
a codo en contra de la invasión rusa
según el presidente ucraniano su
proyecto de combatientes extranjeros
cuenta con 16.000 voluntarios Ucrania ha
empezado a acoger a los voluntarios
extranjeros que vienen a nuestro país
los primeros de 16.000 vienen a defender
la libertad y la vida de nosotros Y de
todos Estoy seguro que será un éxito
para cumplir con su objetivo excelencia
aprobó el pasado martes un decreto que
exime de visado a los combatientes
extranjeros que se sumen a la denominada
legión internacional Según la ley
Quienes cuentan con 18 a 40 años pueden
unirse a las fuerzas armadas tras
demostrar que están física y mentalmente
aptos para combatir a este grupo se le
suman los ucranianos expatriados que
regresan para defender su país natal del
ataque ruso como este hombre de 44 años
que asegura estar listo para luchar
es mi padre tengo que defenderla todavía
soy joven tengo fuerza necesito defender
el anuncio llega cuando se cumple una
semana de haber iniciado el ataque ruso
sobre Ucrania y mientras Se incrementa
el asedio sobre la capital kiev la
segunda ciudad del país harco y uno de
los puertos comerciales más importantes
del sur Mario Polo selensky aseguró que
Ucrania ya no tiene nada que perder más
que su propia libertad Confía en el
armamento diario que sus socios
internacionales envían al país y Espera
que entre tanto se logre un avance en
los esfuerzos diplomáticos que se
adelantan con Rusia en belarús